I have been checking out this new AI
powered scam detection app called Norton
Genie and it's actually made a huge
difference in helping me to identify
scams online thank you to Norton for
sponsoring this video let me show you
more about it so when you're in the app
it gives you the option to add a text or
an image like a screenshot of your email
a screenshot of text messages or
something that you found on the web now
when you upload it it runs the detection
over the image or text and most
importantly they're checking those links
for you to see if they are safe or a
scam I also love that once it's done
doing a scan it has this conversational
chat about the results and if it is a
scam it takes you through some questions
and precautions in case you interacted
with the link I think this is such a
great tool keep people educated about
what scams are actually out there so now
I'm having it check a screenshot of text
messages that I got from a store that I
signed up so like this is actually not
spam so it says from what I can tell
this doesn't seem to be a scam I'm glad
I tested this because I was curious to
see if it would actually detect
something that I signed up for and guess
what it looks to be okay good to know
check out Norton Genie and let me see if
you can outsmart the scammers it's free